الاف يصرفها الطلاب وسنوات يقضونها من
اعمارهم مقابل شهاده جامعيه تضمن مستقبلهم
فهل تستحق الجامعه هذا العناء الكبير
لنجيب عن هذا السؤال يجب ان نعود بالزمن
لسبعينات القرن الماضي عندما حدث الطفره
ادت لرفع راتب الموظف صاحب الشهاده
الجامعيه بنسبه 35% اكثر من الموظف خريج
الثانويه النسبه هذه وصلت الى 66% بحلول
عام 2021 الا انما اختلف مؤخرا هو ارتفاع
عدد حماله الشهادات وارتفاع رسوم الجامعات
مقابل ركود رواتب الموظفين وانخفاضها في
بعض القطاعات فمعهد الدراسات الماليه
البريطانيه نشر بحثا اظهر ان 25% من
الخريجين و15 من الخريجات في بريطانيا
سيحصلون على مرتبات اقل في حياتهم مقارنه
باقرنهم الذين لم يتخرجوا من الجامعه ما
رايكم هل الشهاده الجامعيه تضمن مستقبلا
افضل لحامليها